there we go let's talk about merrier
um so i've taken a whole lot of work
doing
variably pretentious job titles like
head of engineering and
chief technical architect and principal
engineer all these
you know all those job titles that sound
a lot fancier than they really
are because what i really like doing is
making comments and i love making things
i love spending time with the people
that make things and i love trying to
make them do things a little bit better
i've written a couple of kids books
about programming
websites and games get coding one and
two in all good bookstores
etc uh but recently more more
interestingly i made it
a gameboy emulator
so so what is emulation when i say the
word emulation
we should probably talk about a little
bit
emulation is the practice of writing
software on one system
so that can simulate the runtime
environment of another
normally with the goal of running
software designed for a different piece
of hardware or environment
now there's a couple of different
approaches to emulation that you can
take
you have low level emulation where you
implement the behavior
of the raw hardware and then the
software designed for it should
just work and then we also have high
level emulation
which is where you attempt to run the
software natively on your target
platform and intercept and re-implement
certain system level calls
so most game system emulators are a mix
of these two things
often emulating low-level hardware
architecture
while re-implementing things like 3d
drawing calls in higher level
modern apis
there are plenty of famous emulators
from
games console emulators to operating
system emulators
even to hardware emulators so you know
if you're running any kind of virtual
machine or a vm that is a kind of
emulation
so when i say i built a game boy
emulator
what i'm really saying is that i built a
program that can run game boy software
while the gameboy software itself
believes it's running on game boy
hardware
which is a little bit of a tongue
twister
but the most important question kind of
comes first why on earth would you build
a game boy emulator why would you do
that
i i know it is really a bit pointless
but that's kind of the fun of
experimentation
there's a lot of different answers to
this question
but mostly i just i wanted to see if i
could
it is so often that we're forced to live
in a brutalistic
corporate hellhole where only things
that have to exist for money
get rendered into reality this is the
total
opposite of that no one is ever going to
get paid because of this i don't want to
get paid because of this
and game boy emulators already exist
please please please please please don't
use my emulator
and we're back okay sorry about that
clearly technical difficulties can you
give me a wave if you can see me
and you can hear me perfect thank you
very much i'm going to start this slide
again
um so why would you build a gameboy
emulator
like it is a little bit pointless um
but there's a lot of different answers
to the question ultimately but i wanted
to do it because it wasn't for money i
wanted to do it because it's not
corporate and because it's not boring
software
and because it's kind of a different
thing you can do with your skills
um so if you want to play game boy games
please i'm going to start now with
like don't use my emulator it's
it's incomplete it's possibly buggy
and i'm not going to help you wake the
wind fish and links awakening
right but this the story is a little bit
different than that and it actually
starts in the 1970s
with a game called pong and an
interpreted programming language called
chip 8. and what we're going to do is
we're going to use it to understand what
emulation
really is before we talk about game boys
and before we talk about mario
and another way to make sure you can see
my slides
perfect thank you very much everybody
okay so chip 8
sounds delicious right so
i started toying around with emulators
as part of
what i suppose now is a decade-long
experiment in running coding dojos
i do a lot of training for teams and
especially web dev teams
and they're looking to upskill or pick
up tdd or learn how to write better
tests
so while looking for different puzzles
for dojos i plundered the archives of
this wonderful old website called ruby
quiz
which is still online it's on
rubyquiz.com like check it out if you're
interested in this kind of stuff as
attention
and what they did is they used to run
weekly programming puzzle contests
where people would literally email in
solutions in ruby
cool and i ended up running
their chip eight cutter quite a few
times it's quiz 88
if you're looking for it and the the
chip8 ketter provides a binary program
written in
a language called chip a it's a machine
language
and it tasks you with writing an
interpreter for it along with outlining
the hardware that the program should run
on
so chip 8 has 32 op codes
in total and don't worry if you don't
know what that really means we're going
to break it down in painful detail
and the program supplied by the quiz
actually only uses a subset of them to
make the quiz a little bit more
approachable
because i remember thinking like it
sounded absolutely terrifying the first
time i read it like oh cool you want me
to write an interpreter for a machine
language i've never heard
that sounds like something i can do
so op codes machine languages what the
hell
let's look at a quick example of how
computers
and specifically our computer processors
and our cpus work
before we go any further so when
processors are manufactured
they're built to implement a specific
instruction set
so this instruction set is the list of
things
the processor can do anybody old enough
to remember might remember the 1990s
competition between
sisk and risk architectures
which stands for complex instruction set
and reduced instruction set computing
respectively now the these instructions
these cpu instructions are what they
were referring to
the instructions are built into the
physical hardware and they can be
programmed using machine code
now every processor or family of
processors
has its own instruction set and as a
result it has its own machine code
now machine code is is strictly
numerical
and it's a strictly numerical
representation of the operations that a
processor can perform
so you've got a lot of numbers that can
work with a processor
an op code shortened from operation code
is the part of the machine code
which specifies what operation the cpu
should do
as a result of that at one level up the
assembly language for a given processor
can be assembled into this machine code
basically compiled
and is a low-level abstraction over the
instruction set of your processor
so when we talk about assembly languages
and people often will mention
assembly languages what they really mean
is the assembly language
for a specific cpus instruction set
now the cpu in hardware implements
operations so things like add two
numbers together
or take a number from here and put it in
this memory location
and the op code when a cpu is running a
program
tells the cpu which instruction to
execute when it encounters it
so i appreciate this all sounds really
abstract so let's look at the example
above and see
where all those moving parts really are
so in the example on on the left you can
see the raw machine code of a chip8
program
and we're going to revisit this a few
times and that same machine code
decompiled into its corresponding
instructions is on the right hand side
besides the opcode itself most
instructions
also specify the data that they're going
to process in the form of operands
just kind of think of them as parameters
that get passed to an opcode
and normally those parameters are a
memory address
or a register address and a register if
you don't know
is just some memory that lives on on the
processor itself
so a memory address is just a number
it's normally expressed in hexadecimal
but they're just numbers really and they
start at zero
and they count up to however much memory
you have
so it's interesting because i remember
in the 90s there was always a big thing
especially in video games about 16-bit
32-bit
and this bitness got used as marketing
terms
so when people talk about how many bits
a cpu
i suppose is has um they're referring to
the largest number a computer can hold
in its memory when expressed in
hexadecimal
the more bits the larger the total
amount of memory a cpu can addresses
so a cpu that only understands eight bit
numbers
can only understand the numbers zero to
two five five
therefore it can only address 256 memory
locations
a cpu that understands 16 bit numbers
can only understand the numbers from
naught to 65 535 which which again means
it can only address
a total of 65 300 and 536
memory locations so literally it can
just keep a bigger numbery
number in memory and each memory
location can store an amount of data
so in the case of chip 8 a memory
address stores 8 bytes of data
and the chip 8 hardware has 4096 memory
locations
cool so we've got some numbers and we've
got cpus that can refer to locations
this is like the foundation of all
computing i think you could probably go
away and like
say you've done cs101 now probably
if you have you haven't so when you use
a higher level programming language like
c
sharp or javascript though the run times
that execute these specific programs
have been compiled down for your
specific cpu architecture
that means that ultimately somewhere
something
has been translated down to machine code
and is running on your cpu
and whether you create vari whenever you
create variables in your programs
somewhere something is putting things in
memory registers
it's all buried under like epic amounts
of abstraction
most memory manipulation is done by
interacting with an operating system
the operating system decides what libs
where in memory
you know often if you're running c sharp
you've got the clr or net core runtime
you're running javascript you've got
node that interacts with the operating
system
but when you write code that puts
something
in a variable all the way down the stack
this stuff happens for every single line
of code you ever write
so
after our crash course on how processors
work
let's look at a chip 8 program and some
of the op codes that it uses
so the program in the top left portion
of the slide is just the original ruby
quiz
chip 8 test program it's a raw binary
file in machine in the machine language
of a chip 8 computer
that when opened in a hex editor looks
like that
to interpret this program you would loop
through each of the bytes
and if you look at the snippet of c
sharp on on the left
on the right even we're just loading
this file as a byte array
and printing it to the screen so in c
sharp the bytes are all represented in
base 10
as integers but notice how the first
number that gets printed
97 is the same as
61 in hexadec in hexadecimal and if you
look at the first
two digits of the original program at
the top this is that same
61 in the start of our test program
those first two
two numbers so our documentation shows
that our chip 8
interpreter operates on two byte op
codes
so to run this program we need to loop
through all of our pairs of bytes
in this case we read 61 and 77 together
and then we process them according to
whatever the hardware behavior is
and that's the very very foundations the
fundamentals of emulating anything
so let's zoom in on those first two
bytes from the file those two hex
numbers 6177
the two of them make up an op code and
its operand
so if you look in the the manual
they call this 6xkk
and it's explained in the original ruby
quiz as setting the memory location
x to the constant value kk
in this case 6177
kk is an 8 bit constant it is literally
the hexadecimal value 77
so it's the number 119 that's what it
means
so our first op code says 6
that's the op code 1 a constant the
memory address 1
and 77 the decimal number 119
which translated into english says put
the hexadecimal number 77
into memory location 1.
so if you imagine memory locations as an
array or like a big excel spreadsheet
for all i care
you can interpret this entire chip 8
program by implementing
each one of those op codes and writing a
little bit of code to perform the logic
with the different op codes in this case
the number 6
doing different things so this is a
scary looking problem but it's actually
not so complicated under the hood
because when you do that first ruby quiz
you realize the solution to it
is a switch statement with like eight
cases
and that's it right that that's the
whole the answer to quiz sorry spoilers
um but the great thing about it as a
challenge is because it's so far out
from what people normally find
themselves working on
people attending the dojos where i ran
this quiz always found it exciting
because
like they felt they were making progress
in something a world away from their
normal work
and i ended up running this particular
coding dojo a lot with plenty of
different audiences because i think
there's nothing more fun
than taking people who think their only
real skills are taking numbers from a
database and putting them on web pages
and showing them just how capable and
awesome they can be with like a little
bit of lateral thinking
and that really programming isn't just
this horrible blunt commercial thing
it can be fun and challenging and
enjoyable
so like the end right cool go go go do
chip hey i i jest
um you now know how to write an emulator
end of demo um
no let's talk about game boys let's talk
about game boys so
chip a is a useful introduction to this
kind of low-level programming because
there are only 32 relatively simple op
codes to implement
and the ruby quiz cata even more so
because it only uses so few of them
the principles are exactly the same but
if i was to take you through every op
code in the game boy
it would hurt your brain
it's really important to remember that
anyone can do things like this right so
i'm not a particularly incredible
programmer
but i can read and i can reason and
i really wanted to know that if given a
background of building smaller machine
code interpreters
i could do something bigger and so
game boys bigger
so what's a gameboy more or less
literally nobody ever asked
um i'll do the wikipedia thing first a
gameboy is an 8-bit handheld game
console developed and manufactured by
nintendo
the first handheld in the game boy
family it was first released in japan on
april 21st 1989
then north america three months later
and leslie in europe over a year later
it was designed by the same team that
developed the game and watching several
nintendo entertainment system games
i don't know whoever writes those really
really dry things for wikipedia but it
is a life skill
um i mean we all know what a game boy is
right and
that they're they're absolutely iconic
you can set them on fire apparently and
they still work
true story they saw off about 50 billion
competitor consoles by being simple
accessible resilient and fun
like this is my childhood legitimately
this is my childhood in a little plastic
mold
and it's where my lifelong obsession
with games probably came from
and i literally just typoed game from in
my speaker notes
like game boys are freaking awesome and
personally
i i remember growing up in asia in the
80s and i i got my game boy
i don't know if you can see it here this
actual game boy the screen covering just
fell off
i got it in the temple street night
market in in hong kong
and i remember being a kid like so
excited and looking at the big
walls of like colorful box art
cartridges in the game stores
like it's a proper emotional thing so
not only is the game boy awesome
but like it feels somehow deeply
personal to me
but we don't care where you brought your
game boy i hear you all thinking
programming what is a game boy
uh fine so the game boy
has an 8-bit 4.19 megahertz cpu
it's got 8 kilobytes of ram a 160 by 144
pixel display and the game boy cpu is
similar to an older intel 8080
and most of the same the assemblers for
it use z80 style syntax
um so it's a custom chip but most of the
instructions are similar to other
well-known processes
cool so i read those technical specs
right and i was like
yeah yeah i felt emboldened it's just
like the z80
they're like really old how hard can
this possibly be
um well i adore games and i always have
and i love the 90s and 2000s emulation
and porting scene right
but so but a few things specifically
ended up sending me down this path
where i thought oh how hard could this
possibly be so i watched this really
great youtube video
um on a channel called modern vintage
gamer i don't know if you've ever seen
it
this guy's wonderful and he did a time
lapse video of him porting
the the game another world to the
original xbox live and he did it like
live on stream
and i'd spent some time in the past
couple of years transliterating
software for various clients so when i
say transliteration i was porting python
and java into dotnet and.net core
and quite ironically porting a lot.net
core and c-sharp stuff into typescript
and javascript
so i felt kind of confident
transliterating between these languages
and i've been working on some cnc plus
hardware projects around building
wearable
led displays so i kind of thought hey
like the z80 processor it's not too
different from chip 8 and complexity
totally not true
um i wonder if i can write a lo-fi game
boy emulator and
we could use it to capture frames and
build some like mad wearable game boy
that sounds cool um to be confirmed
and so i fell into this black hole of
1990s era pdfs
about reverse engineering the game boy
and you know like when you fall into
those wikipedia black holes that you
lose like four hours to
and you end up reading about the capital
of a country that didn't exist after
this was one of those holes and it ran
really really deep
the 90s were wild man
so i spent about a day reading this
thing called pens docs
a 25-year long community effort to
catalogue
all of the details of the game boy
hardware this is like some
peak 1990s era deep technical reverse
engineering
it's like totally totally a head full
uh they're wonderful docs but i'd
probably not recommend them as casual
bedtime reading
you know the no plot the characters are
boring
i i skipped to what i felt was the most
interesting place to start which was
loading some information from
cartridges and i opened visual studio
and i started to code
and i wrote that so
well from the frame of reference of
writing an entire emulator
passing a cartridge might not seem like
much of a big deal
but i managed to get it done pretty
quickly i
grabbed my copy of my totally legally
backed up nintendo i promise
super mario land rom right here
right here it's fine this is mine um
in case i need an alibi and i managed to
pass the boot logo right and
and the cartridge information and the
metadata within a few hours of hacking
around
and i was like super excited because i
could read the text super mario land
um it felt real like i had some virtual
memory
i made myself a cpu class and some op
codes and i was like
yes i'm gonna i'm gonna do this thing
then i got really really really
catastrophically stuck
so i felt like i had a reasonable grasp
of the game boy hardware
but i i couldn't understand what some of
my op codes were meant to do
and my emulator kept crashing in its
boot sequence
and to make matters more confusing the
documentation now i do not have like an
electronic engineering background or
anything
it started using notation that i
literally didn't understand i couldn't
even read the docs
and uh and i'm sure it's some fairly
like standard high school maths but it
was totally boiling my brain
so i was trying to implement the op
codes for the game boy cpu just like in
our earlier chip a
example and i kept getting lost in the
documentation
and i was stuck so not to be deterred
i went hunting for some other code bases
that have been here before
in an attempt to find something that
could literally help me read the
documentation i was looking at
and the game boy is quite a popular like
first emulation target
because it's relatively accessible
so i found a couple of emulators that
worked in a couple of different
languages
um and i stumbled upon a project called
coffee gb
like a working emulator in java 1.8
and like this this is wonderful this is
a revelation like i opened up the game
and it worked i could clone it i could
reason about it and it was in a language
i understood
so at this point i figured i could try
transl
transliterate this mit licensed open
source code base
and use some of the tests that were
written for it
and then kind of glue the things
together at the end
and i started off by like i lost an
entire day converting coffee gb from
java to kotlin
like it worked but there wasn't really
any point like i thought it would make
it look closer to c-sharp so it'd be
easier to pull
and then i decided to just commit to
doing a like for like full
conversion a full transliteration of the
java source
into netcore31 in an attempt to
hopefully understand where my opco
processing approach had differed and
where my code was crashing on boop
so i keep on using this word like
transliterate so let's talk about that
in in deep detail
um the this is originally a language
term that means to write or print
a letter or word using the closest
corresponding letters
of a different alphabet or script so for
a little bit of clarification a
transliteration
as opposed to a full-blown software port
is a line for line
cosmetic only change like we're
literally going to change the minimum
amount required to get
the software compiling in the target
language and then we will end up doing
subsequent second and third passes to
turn that transliteration
into a real port for things that are
missing or don't quite convert like for
like
supporting and transliterating software
is a very very specific discipline
which is counter to how i'd normally
build software
and ultimately you have to think about
it in three three passes
so firstly you have to transliterate
until it compiles
so you work from an entry point down
normally involving starting at the main
method
and only migrating code that gets called
file by file
you end up with lots and lots of stuff
commented on so secondly you port over
any test suite
once the transliteration is done and
ensure that the tests match the original
so you've converted form not fun and
function
and then thirdly you convert the code to
be idiomatic in its host language
so that's what i would normally regard
as actually porting software at the end
like changing the way something worked
so in the examples above you can see how
the java is subtly changed into c-sharp
package declarations swapped for
namespaces
attributes being removed and later much
of the syntax being converted into c
sharp a using expression bodied methods
so this is a fairly trite and succinct
example just to fit on some slides
um as some of the other conversions are
far far more dramatic
so it might seem like a set of obvious
steps but you have to do some really
natural
unnatural things sometimes that are
going to totally go against your
instincts
so during the first phase especially
you're going to often find yourself
fighting your tools because you're
you're at a disadvantage if you diverge
the code in any way that prevents like
for like comparisons
this means you're gonna have to keep all
the naming conventions you're gonna have
to keep the casings and odd
non-idiomatic qualities of a foreign
code base
precisely as they are until you get to a
point of safety
you're going to have to get very very
comfortable just throwing not
implemented exceptions like
everywhere where a direct equivalent is
is not
available until you've managed to get
the code executing
and the sooner you can start
transliterating any available tests the
better
because you're going to start to know
early on if you're going off track
so ideally to do this you have to have a
good enough reading grasp of the source
language
add a relatively advanced grasp of the
target language to be able to convert
some of the more subtle differences
in this particular code base so
something you may or may not know is
that java has
quite rich genomes and you can put
behavior load
into enums in java and we totally like
that in c sharp
the construct just doesn't exist so
producing similar syntactic constructs
that could be used in the same way
is important and i ended up like
stitching extension methods onto enums
and all sorts of crazy stuff
and what that does is it requires a
reasonable mastery of the target
language to pull off
without getting yourself confused and
stuck in a non-compiling code base
so
once i found my groove with
transliterating the coffee gb
code base a couple of things became
apparent
firstly the ui would not port
at all just like not at all not even
remotely
because it was a bunch of jwt java
window toolkit
code and there was absolutely no point
in trying to convert
that like for like because i wasn't here
to produce a weird c-sharp port of jwt
so the jwt code was also responsible for
drawing the game on the screen
and handling controller inputs so cool
fine i've got my to-do list there's two
things that are gonna have to be
completely different
my first target quickly as a result of
that became to get the headless mode in
the original codebase booting a gameboy
cartridge
so headless mode was designed to run the
emulator without visual
output or controls in a console window
and it was used in the test suite
i just figured if i could do enough to
get that running i could port the unit
tests
and then i could exercise some of the
community authored homebrew roms that
are designed to test various aspects
of the gameboy hardware
and i deleted all the jwt code and i
maintained all the code paths that
called into it
replacing the method bodies with not
implemented exceptions
i implemented a few interfaces with
empty implementations and i managed to
basically cajole
the headless mode into life you can if
you look at the screenshot you can see
the code for headless mode as it still
exists today
in the source passing in null displays
and controllers and sound
um along with amusingly the remnants of
some jwt stuff commented out
for reference
so i can't state enough
how well compartmentalized the original
code base was
i was very very lucky when it came to
writing a new display
that the original code kept an array of
internal pixel colors packed into
integers
right um and those integers
com combined with the various graphics
op codes
produced a display image and i knew that
all i had to do
at that point was convert an array of x
y coordinates and find a way to just
like get it on the screen
because i had pixel colors and locations
so i extracted the rgb values from this
packed integer
and i raised the c-sharp event in my new
bitmap display class
um so i did this to match the original
implementation
and made sure the display is running on
its own thread
which refreshes distinctly from the cpu
emulation that's ticking at the same
time
i just needed something to subscribe to
my event with all my pixels
and draw them on a screen somewhere
and um yeah legitimately win forms to
the rescue
like not even joking you totally heard
me right win forms
um so let's let's just um unpack this
here i ported a game boy emulator to
dotnet core 31
just to run it in a wim forms ui and i'm
totally not sorry
and i would totally do it again um the
number of questions i got re
my sanity really why i wasn't using wpf
if anyone still used wim forms if you
could even run wim forms on.net core
we're all totally excellent um people
kind of forget that winforms was
designed to be so easy to use
and really rapid application development
friendly
and it lets you get stuff on the screen
really quickly right so winforms is
secretly kind of awesome
and it also i believe last year was
ported to run on net core
so it totally just works obviously net
core only on windows
so in about 200 lines of code i had a
wim forms ui with a picture box on it
that i could update with the current
frame every time the emulator raised an
event
if you're eagle-eyed and look closely
through the background images here
the other thing that came free with wim
forms was input handling
so i could hook an implementation of the
controller up just like the jwt thing in
the java code pasted
um and i could hook them up to just wim
forms key press events
so yeah like winforms is amazing
don't quote me on that and and it kind
of worked
like totally totally kind of kind of
worked
um so once i got to the point where i
had the title screen of mario
booting in c sharp and side by side the
original java code base
booting the same game i realized that
i'd made some kind of
terrible terrible error where my game
would crash as soon as i started running
it
so obviously enough of my port was
working
that there was stuff on the screen right
and
and establishing where my code diverged
on the other hand was
very very tricky so luckily i'm not the
first person to ever try and write a
game boy emulator
there's this like really great set of
homebrew test rooms
that exercise different parts of the
game boy hardware which i could run in
both emulators to see where they
diverged
their wonderfully named blog with 3gs
and moon eye
which uh test roms like i think the moon
eye suite is actually from a work in
progress rust emulator
so i ported the test harness across from
the original code base
and i got these test runs i had them
running and as i suspected the tests
that were passing in the original java
code base were failing in my port
so i'd made a mistake and this was a
great first step because i had failing
tests
i just needed to find out what and where
i had broken something
so i mentioned earlier the idea of low
level emulation where you're emulating
the hardware
well both of these emulators are
low-level emulators and what that means
is they literally
implement the opcodes of the hardware as
code
and they tick at the clock rate of the
cpu
you can't meaningfully step through the
code
because the number of operations that
you have to complete at the clock rate
at the cpu to see any actual change in
memory state is like
i don't know it's a really big number
it's a lot it's
many many many operations hundreds of
thousands
so but that's okay right we live in
visual studio and we have amazing things
like conditional break points that can
help us
see where values change right
well ironically the performance overhead
of applying a conditional break point to
one of my virtual cpu registers was so
severe
that i couldn't even get visual studio
to process the test cases as far as the
first error
in less than 10 minutes on like a
top-end horizon
uh it just couldn't churn through the
numbers fast enough because clearly vs
was hooking
in its debug process so i knew that i
could i get both code bases
if i could get both code bases to a
break point where their memory states
diverged
i could totally solve the problems i was
seeing i just wasn't immediately sure
how
when because when your debugger doesn't
work what do you do
i was suffering from this pain of my
integration tests being
my main tests right like a common
pattern in all software
so so i spent a morning building
some tools i started by building a
debugger i built a debugging tool
with a client in both java and c-sharp
that would keep the ticks of both
emulators in sync
and it would break them both into the
regular debugger when their memory state
differed
so both emulators would call a http
server with the hash of their current
memory state
and when it differed i tell them to both
pause and it was really nice in theory
but
in practice it only helped me find one
bug
because obviously if visual studio's
built-in conditional debugger was slow
making network requests over the network
as we stepped forward was definitely
more slow
so it was a little bit too much overhead
and i thought okay cool i can't do this
let's go lo-fi so i built a logging
function into each emulator that i could
wrap around the test cases
that dumped the memory state to a
massive log file
on every single cpu tick i knew that
when the test passed in the first
emulator
because they kind of ran at similar
speeds i could stop the failing test if
it was still executing in another
emulator
the number of lines in the file would
tell me how far i'd ticked forwards
and what i ended up doing was doing
lengthy diffs of these many gigabyte
long log files
like you run these tests for 30 seconds
and you'll have 4 gig of text
to find the tick number that the
emulators diverged on so i just did a
diff tool and i found the tick number
once i had the take the tick number i
added an if statement to my emulator
with a debugger break
when the the tick number matched
so the world's most low-fi debugging
technique
um it was important because i kept the
transliterated code base
very close to the original while i was
doing this testing process
actually this debugging worked and
wasn't a nightmare
so i could put the same shaped if
statement on the same tick in both code
bases
and get both of my emulators frozen in a
break point
you know what like the the sense of
accomplishment you get from building
your own debugging tools and it actually
working is insane
like it felt like magic when i actually
managed to get these two damn emulators
into a break point that matched
it took about a day's work but i had
them both in parity with the original
source and i could start refactoring
so what what was the bug the what was
the crashing bug
so i fell fell of converting one of the
java data structures to c-sharp
so in java as i mentioned before enums
can have
methods and hastily transliterated some
of the code that categorized enums for
the different memory banks and the game
boy cartridges
so you'll notice if you glance to the
top right here that enum names are used
to categorize different parts of
the same type of memory for instance
rom mbc3 and rom mbc
3 ram are both identifying parts of
memory that make up
mbc 3 which is a memory bank controller
inside a game boy cartridge game boy
cartridges use this idea of memory banks
to expand the amount of memory
available to games this is why the size
of the cartridges were used in
marketing material in the day games with
more data more switchable memory banks
could get larger and you could store
more graphics
so the bigger the the size of the
cartridge generally the better the game
looked
so the code in the emulator that
implemented the op code to switch
between memory banks
needed to check if the current memory
location was part of one of these memory
banks
now the original java implementation
used a regular expression to check
if the name of the enum member
contained the name of the memory bank it
was looking for so it seems nice and
simple
so i had hastily replaced that with a
string contains call
that presumed that the enum member would
always have an underscore
followed by the mbc value followed by an
underscore
cool which works totally perfectly well
for for the string rom underscore mbc 3
underscore rem but not so well for rom
underscore mbc 3 because it lacked that
trailing underscore right
so while trying to switch memory banks
my code was crashing
quickly replacing um my string contains
method
back to the original x regular
expression totally fixed the bug
it's likely there are plenty more
idiomatic c-sharp ways to mark up enums
normally you know you would add
attributes to provide this kind of
categorization
and do some kind of meta programming but
you know what that's probably a little
bit too slow
so one of the final entertaining
surprises
was the afternoon that i lost trying to
work out why
my emulator was slow so on a related
note
you'd be really surprised what a
difference to performance release builds
make
like those buttons do mean something
so i spent what felt like an eternity
trying to profile the performance of the
emulator
because i couldn't work out why it was
performing so badly
and the irony was it was because it was
being observed
the program was ticking so fast that the
overhead of collecting
metrics and debugging in visual studio
slowed the program
down so that the two emulators side by
side mine was noticeably slower
simply compiling and running in release
mode and without a debugger attached
showed that it was running totally fine
totally as benchmarked and used minimal
cpu
so i've kind of skirted around the audio
in the emulator because well
awkward there isn't any
yeah i've not written it yet i've never
really done audio programming before
and um i'm looking into various audio
wrappers
probably starting with n audio to see if
i can work out how to make the audio
sing again
because i don't know about you but when
i look at game boy cartridges like i can
hear the
the theme song to mario playing in my
head when i see
this picture it's that like iconic um
the original java implementation used a
very very java very very java open
source
audio thing which again just like i
didn't want to port jwt
i probably don't want to port an entire
audio library to make this happen
so throughout the first couple of weeks
of this project
and and given that we're all in
quarantine at the moment well the
unlucky ones
i've been teasing the internet with
screenshots of game boy games relatively
hard
so once i got to a point where the ui
wasn't crashing
and the code was suitably ported i just
kind of picked up the emulator and
stuffed it on github and shared it
around
right mostly for the fun of it
and generally people have enjoyed seeing
this kind of project
done in c-sharp rather than like yet
another business application
yet another boring like data access
example
oh and i stuck like a ridiculous ascii
art renderer
on the command line so you can
technically play game boy games in ascii
art if you want to
which was kind of fun because why would
you not want to do that it
it took like 20 minutes and really there
was that was the reason for doing it at
all right like that was the reason so c
sharp is a language i totally love
a language i feel very comfortable with
and i love the direction that
dotnetcore.net5.net whatever the
branding is this week
um is taking at the moment and i'm on a
bit of a journey to prove that really
any place that another language can do
something.net core is at least as good
at least as performing and often plenty
more beautiful at doing the same thing
and it's kind of wonderful to see people
being really responsive and taking it in
that spirit and
feeling the same way so though obviously
when you put something online it's um
let's say it's not without its
detractors never never read the comments
they say never read the comments but i'm
a glutton for punishment
and i like to engage and there was one
comment that really
both stuck with me and i think is
important enough to highlight
code quality is questionable here's how
the author emits frames they create a
new image they iterate over every pixel
they convert its value to a string they
pass it back as a source they create a
memory stream they encode it as a bitmap
they're called two array
this is some electron level saw resource
wasting
reddit as ever is a mixed bag um so
totally true i had a bunch of really
interesting conversations with people in
the dot net and c-sharp subreddits
and the general programming subreddit on
the other hand
absolutely not so much um it's really
easy to forget how hostile people can be
to absolutely nothing at all
but legitimately this is one of the big
takeaways of this process for me
like as programmers we can be short and
snipey and dig through code
contextless taking swipes at things
basically just bringing each other down
and like that whole comment is totally
true like it could definitely be better
but like you know what the program
consumes 30 to 50 megabytes of memory in
total
i benchmarked it and i would do this
all again in exactly the same way in a
heartbeat
to put something cool and working out
into the world that people enjoy
so let's like hear this loud and clear
no gatekeepers
no perfection like there is no such
thing
do the fun thing enjoy yourselves and
share stuff
or we let tedious bores like whoever
that guy was win
luckily the boars never win in in the
face of people doing cool stuff
right so within a day or two of pushing
some tweets out with links to the code i
already had two pull requests
one with a mono game ui that let the
emulator run on various devices
the other with an avalonia ui that the
emulator run on linux and mac
as well as the existing wim forms ui
that i glued on the top of it and the
headless cross platform
scr head cli oh and you can also
reference this emulator as a library
in your own net projects if you want to
use it which is amazing because
literally in the last two weeks
there's a guy that's just done like a
twitter plays pokemon thing
where you can tweet him gameboy controls
and his user picture
changes to control a game of pokemon
that uses this behind
the scenes and i got a message literally
two days ago someone who's doing a
similar thing
with like a discord plays pokemon where
he's averaging the chat inputs
and streaming the the image snapshots
straight into his discord channel right
this is what happens when you do fun
things you let people build cooler stuff
on top of it
so you know the takeaway from me is that
i'm very happy i didn't give up when i
got stuck
this isn't the journey this isn't the
journey that i thought i was going to go
on when i started writing this
but that's fine like i know it sounds
trite but everything we do in software
is built on the shoulders of other
talented people
that built things before us and it's so
easy to get stuck
and give up and it's hard to go and
decide to look around for inspiration
so i'm really really thankful for the
wonderfully high quality coffee gp code
base that i have the pleasure
of adapting and merging with my own
efforts i'm really happy that i didn't
succumb to my own hubris
and decide that if i couldn't just work
it out on my own that it wasn't worth
doing
and like i'm absolutely thrilled that by
sacrificing that little bit of ego
for something cool and fun that people
can play with and adapt
and do their own thing with as well so
for my end i really hope that you all
have fun maybe pushing some of this code
around or tearing it apart
or seeing what you could do better right
that's the point
and and that's the talk about game boy
so i'm going to do a really really quick
demo but you can obviously find me on
the internet in all of those places
on the twitters on email whatever please
ask me questions the code is on github
rip it off rip it off steal all the
stuff and let's
let's run it let's run it for a bit of
fun
here's the actual emulator and it can
load a rom
and we can play super mario
in c-sharp
that's the real thing um
and that's the end of the talk does
anyone have any questions i'm going to
stop sharing my screen so i can see all
your beautiful faces
i don't think you need son because the
music was playing in my head when you
were doing that anyway
right like exactly that like just
everyone just come along and you know
exactly how it works
no i love it like it was such a fun
thing to do honestly and um
it's been so good to see people pushing
the code around in ways that i didn't
have the time or the inclination
to to get done and the wild thing is it
was only like a
i think i spent two weeks on it like two
weeks as as
as a day job i was getting up in the
morning and working on it and working on
it
and it's kind of amazing what you can do
if you just
read the docs honestly just read the
docs and march forwards
cool well thank you so much for coming
everybody like if you
let me um let's even get a link in the
chat as well
of the the github
if you want to have a play with it
you'd think i would prepare all this in
advance but i don't
it is uh where is the chat
that's a that's a more interesting
question okay cool
everyone into chat messages cool yeah
sorry about the technical error in the
middle
uh my my internet connection decided
obviously this was the perfect time to
disconnect for about two minutes
um so i hope there's no glitches in the
recording
perfect thank you so much everybody